Prof: Last time we
started talking about tropical
places where high productivity
agriculture is generally just
not possible.
Hence, without productive
agriculture you can't support
dense populations.
Those cultures grew up in
time--in places where plenty of
land, land was not filled up,
it was people that were scarce.
While individual women of
course still had to control
their fertility so that the
children--
the infants that they had
didn't die and there's many,
many things that they do for
that.
The community cultural controls
on fertility are generally
absent because from the
community point of view you
always wants to be,
at that time,
larger and among other reasons
to protect your community from
the ravages of hostile neighbors
because almost all of these
communities are--
just read any history of any
part of the world constant,
constant warfare,
as we've discussed a lot.
Of many places in the world,
which one could describe,
traditional Africa provides
some of the best examples of how
these cultures operate.
Again, I want to emphasize that
this a tradition--
a picture of a traditional time
and things are changing now
extremely rapidly everywhere in
the world,
including of course Africa.
As I showed you last time,
Africa really is different than
the rest of the world.
I showed statistics comparing
Morocco on the north coast of
Africa, included in the
Mediterranean cultural zone.
You cross the Sahara,
you're in Niger,
or you're in Mali,
and totally different
situation.
The number of children is much
high--
people have is much higher,
I showed you that,
the number of children that
they want is much higher,
infant mortality has come down
in both places,
in Morocco the fertility
responds to it,
in Niger the fertility does not
respond to it.
While we're going--so we're
going to discuss this region and
using a lot of generalizations
which will not fit any
particular culture.
If you add up all the birthrate
statistics, Sub-Saharan African
has about twice the birth rate
of North Africa.
Again, it's all Suni Muslim
we're talking about,
so religion is not the
difference, but the something
else about the southern culture
which we've been talking about.
It probably starts with the
agriculture and then goes into
other fields.
Of all the things that are
changing in Africa,
fertility--the attitudes toward
fertility--
again I'm always using
fertility as the number of
children a woman actually has
and not her ability to have
children.
The attitudes towards fertility
are sort of the most resistant
to change.
These societies have what you
might call a culture of
reproduction in which the
central idea is that of lineage,
a family and its line of male
ancestors.
The prime duty in these
cultures is to keep the lineage
going.
Of course you've all read stuff
about China, China is
not--traditional China is not
particularly different than
this.
The important thing is to
provide descendants for the
ancestors.
Not only is your own future--if
you don't have the son as your
own future as a shade,
as sort of a spirit that hovers
around,
is dependent on continuation of
the line.
The whole history of ancestors,
stretching back,
is dependent on your having
descendants.
The future line which is
perceived as sort of almost in
existence,
of potential existence,
the whole line from the distant
past going through you to the
distant future is all dependent
on you having descendants,
male descendants in the line.
The central purpose,
the central goal,
the central job of existence is
to continue this line of
fertility.
Now the traditional religion is
based on this lineage idea.
Because it's your own--the gods
are in a sense your own
ancestors,
people that you knew,
people that you talk too,
they stay more close to you
after they die.
Unlike Western gods where you
pray but it's never clear
whether your prayers are being
answered or not,
in an ancestor worship
situation, the answer is right
there,
and you can talk back and forth
with them.
They're not distant,
eerie, supernatural kind of
characters but rather like a
grandfather who just stays near
us after his death.
This kind of description comes
from the ethnographers,
the anthropologists that go and
talk to the people in these
traditional cultures.
The lineage head,
who is almost always the old--
often the oldest male member of
the lineage,
he often can communicate
directly with these ancestors or
there may be a soothsayer in the
community and then the head man
will commission the soothsayer
to ask the ancestors some
particular question.
The ancestors are quite
available to discuss the most
ordinary and mundane issues of
life or they can discuss very
weighty affairs.
This doesn't require waiting
for some big holiday or some
huge amount of time,
it can be--the whole thing can
be transacted in 15 minutes or
maybe a half an hour.
Sometimes they're contacted,
they provide their answers,
and you've got the answer that
you need.
One of the interesting,
with respect to this course,
one of the interesting things
that goes on is that family
planning is being introduced
into Africa,
has been now for quite a while,
and it's becoming available.
The people are thinking it
over; it's a hot topic.
They're discussing it,
they're trying to figure out
whether it's good for them or
not,
whether it's permissible for
them or not,
what's going to happen if you
use it,
don't use it.
It's a very hot topic and of
course they want the wisdom of
the ancestors on this.
In the middle of this,
one set of demographers went
into--
in Ghana there's a group of
Nankana--
the name of the people there,
and they went into their
villages and they wanted to see
how this worked out.
If this discussion with the
ancestors, as they call the
traditional religion,
would be hostile to the
introduction of family planning
because elsewhere in the world
of course the more conservative
the more--
it doesn't depend on the
individual religion,
a particular religion as I have
said and will say again,
but it does depend on the
religiosity of the person.
The more religious a person is,
in almost any tradition,
the more hostile they will be
to change,
and in particular to the
adoption of new reproductive
practices like family planning.
They're interested in this
issue how this would work out in
traditional villages in Africa.
He asked the village head
man--one of the
anthropologists--to inquire of
the spirits how many children
should a family have;
a simple question.
Here's what the spirit said,
"Listen to what I have to
say, children are the lineage,
if there are no children the
lineage will end.
We ancestors want many children;
the women should give birth to
many children."
That was a pretty clear answer;
there was no futzing around
with that one.
But being Western skeptics,
they didn't really believe that
the ancestor was saying that,
so he was saying,
well the headman put into the
mouths of the spirits whatever
the headman believed,
and that was not--made the
anthropologists quite satisfied
with this.
He was a good scientist and he
did the control experiment,
he asked the headman,
the same headman who had just
reported the conservative views
of the ancestors.
Well what do you think,
he got a completely different
answer.
"Women need to have just
enough children.
Currently it is very difficult
to fend for the children.
There's no food to feed them.
If they are in school it is
difficult to pay their school
fees and to buy them school
uniforms.
Taking them to the hospital
when they are sick demands a lot
of money.
That is why we need to give
birth to few children."
Well that's a little different
take, and so then the
demographer's brain starts
rolling and says;
now I got the scene,
now I got it right.
The ancestors are giving the
traditional point of view,
well that's true,
that was what the older
generation believed,
but the headmen are part of the
current generation and they're
going to take current views into
consideration and take a more
moderate view.
They interviewed the next--they
went to the next village and
interviewed the next lineage
head and that hypothesis didn't
stand up.
Speaking for himself,
the headman said,
"I would like them to have
many children because a large
following it makes one a chief.
There is power in numbers."
This is the idea that if you
have only a few people in your
village you're not very
powerful,
your neighbors can ignore you,
they can take advantage of you,
but if you have a big set of
descendants and a big family and
extended family,
a big village then you're a
powerful chief and he wanted
children so that he would be
powerful.
But then this same guy was
asked to see what the ancestors
have to say about it,
and the ancestors said,
"Everybody should have a
small number of children,
but they should not refuse to
have children altogether."
Since the ancestors are close
at hand,
it's perfectly reasonable that
they're aware of current trends,
and one of the ancestors said,
"It is now difficult to
get an education as well as to
do farming.
If a problem crops up and the
child is sick then money is
everything.
You have to buy medicine,"
meaning modern medicine,
"And even if you go to the
herbalist,"
traditional medicine,
"You need to take a
fowl," a chicken or
something,
"along to pay for the
treatment.
It's no longer the same as in
the olden days when everybody
did farming."
That's the ancestor speaking,
very well aware of current
trends and problems.
After they interviewed a whole
lot of these Nankana villages in
Ghana they summarized the
research,
and the result was no pattern
of responses at all.
Sometime the headman and his
ancestors they agreed;
sometimes they disagreed;
sometimes it was the ancestor
taking the conservative line;
sometimes it was the headman
taking the conservative line.
It was indeed like a discussion
between a man and say his
grandfather that was going on
and they will have different
points of view and individuals
will be different.
This contact with the ancestors
seems quite natural.
You read this story--you hear
this story as 'oh my God,' but
it's perfectly natural to the
people.
These people in northern Ghana
they have no word for
supernatural.
It just doesn't exist.
They don't have any--they don't
have scientific explanations for
anything,
so all explanations are sort of
somewhere floating around,
some are empirical and
observational,
and some of them are
supernatural,
and so there's no boundary
between these kinds of
explanations for things,
and so they don't have such a
word and they don't distinguish
these kinds of discussions with
the ancestors from real things,
real dreams or daydreams or
anything else.
It's all a very fluid kind of
thing.
To people living in that kind
of a culture the Western idea of
an unwavering set of rules,
cast in stone in some book
thousands of years ago,
like the Bible,
like the Koran,
would seem ludicrous to
Nankana.
To them, our system of a book
that says everything you need to
know is as crazy as our view of
them talking to the ancestors.
You should then compare this
kind of individualistic,
flexible style of religion to
the mass monotheistic religions
that we have in the northern
temperate zones,
at least the Western northern
temperate zones.
These religions are all part of
a big political structure which
requires uniformity of the
subjects of some king,
or some emperor,
and submission to that person.
Of course, as you probably all
know,
the word Islam itself means
'submission' and the ideal in
monotheistic religions is
often--
notice the uniformity.
This is women at prayer and
notice the--
as you see--when you see a
bigger picture of this there's
just a sea of women at some big
event all dressed identically,
all looking identical.
When I was in Morocco I got a
little instruction book that is
given to children about how to
pray,
and every detail is specified
down to when you bow down during
prayer the position of the toes
is specified--
are they curled under,
are they spread out,
you have to know that.
Conformity is a very important
part of mass religion.
Of course in the west how is
conformity enforced in
Christianity?
You burn the heretics,
a long history of burning and
killing by the dominant church,
wherever it is,
you just slaughter the people
that--
even on very tiny theological
differences if they don't
believe exactly as the
authorities think they should
believe,
off with their head,
so it's a very different kind
of pattern of cultural
understanding of religion and
ancestors and the world.
Given this intensity of
devotion to the lineage,
the main virtue in Africa then
is fertility.
The main sin is to be barren,
is not have children.
An inability to have children,
barrenness, is not just a
passive thing that happens to
you but it's punishment for
something bad that you have
done.
There's very little distinction
between infertility,
the woman just can't get
pregnant, and of course they
don't accept the idea that it
might be the man's fault,
but the woman doesn't get
pregnant,
she's infertile,
she has miscarriages,
goes partway through the
pregnancy,
or infant deaths.
The important thing is to have
descendants who can carry on the
line and however--
whatever the mechanism is by
which a man or woman,
or the family,
is incapable of having
descendants,
that's the worst sin and it's
your fault.
It's not a passive thing that
happens to you.
Barren women can be divorced,
they can be shunned,
and sometimes they need
to--they're not even allowed to
live in the center of the
village because--
of course they have no
scientific explanation for
barrenness,
but maybe it's catching in some
sense,
either by evil spirits which
are keeping the woman from
getting pregnant and you don't
want the evil spirits to attack
you,
or some other reason they can
often be required to live on the
edge of the village.
Given this emphasis on,
one way or another,
getting pregnant,
monogamy is not strictly
enforced;
it's not the kind of obsession
that it is in the West.
Here's a wonderful
story--recent 2000,
this is The People Newspaper
from Nairobi,
Kenya.
"A group of women stormed
the Kenya police station to
demand that officers either make
love to them or close illegal
drinking dens.
They said the drinking made
their husbands impotent.
The women said the population
of the district was falling off
as a result of the poor sexual
performance of the men.
The women,"
it was Kanda actually,
north of Nairobi,
"brought the businesses in
town to a halt with their
daylong protest against
excessive drinking by their men
folk.
'Our men have turned to
vegetables;
they leave home early and come
back intoxicated.
There is no one to meet the
sexual needs of the
wives.'"
Guess which group it was where
these women came from?
It was 24 Catholic Church
groups in Kenya.
They came together and demanded
that the officer in charge of
the police station order his men
to make love to these women.
The newspaper discretely does
not say how the police responded
to this demand.
Now--so the women must be
fertile and the men must be
believed to be potent or
fertile, of course it's harder
to tell whether the man is or
isn't.
The men of course,
in a sense, want to keep the
fertility of the women for
themselves but it's more
important to have children no
matter who is the biological
father.
Not only in the family but once
a child is born,
perhaps under obviously
uncertain circumstances,
the village will accept--the
community accepts the children.
They need people;
they want strength in numbers,
and so promiscuity is not
frowned on particularly by the
community.
Everybody knows it goes on and
just keeps quiet.
I was reading this week and
last a history of a Lesotho.
How many--Lesotho is a small
country--you've been there?
No, okay.
A small enclave totally
surrounded by South Africa.
This was a history before the
Europeans came about the 1700s.
There was a king then and the
king,
it was a very small group at
that time,
not much more than a village,
and when the third son--
this is sort of a quote,
"When the third son of the
king died he left a widow who
was still of childbearing age
but had no surviving children.
By custom the widow should have
gone to live with her husband's
younger brother so that she
could continue the seed of her
dead husband."
Exactly as we see in the Old
Testament that we talked about
last time.
The widow didn't agree and she
went off and actually got
pregnant by sort of a no good
who wasn't even of that tribe.
Now this is a real no-no
and--but nevertheless the child,
since that woman was legally
part of a certain lineage,
that child by someone who
wasn't even a member of the
tribe and against the convention
was still accepted as a member
of the king's lineage there.
It turns that the child of
this--illegitimate in a sense--
child became the greatest king
that Lesotho has ever known,
a very important guy named
Moshoeshoe.
Moshoeshoe himself,
the grandson of the time I'm
talking about,
he was reputed to have 140 to
200 wives.
You read the history,
they of course--
they have whatever written
records they have and the first
one says well--
when he was young he has 35
wives, then he has 80 wives,
and every time this is reported
as he gets older,
and probably accumulates more
wives,
the number goes up.
The last report was 200 wives.
Of course we don't know
anything about the accuracy of
this.
But it was said most of his
latter wives were regarded as
distinctly inferior.
Moshoeshoe would summon
whomever he wished to spend the
night with him,
and he undoubtedly sired a vast
progeny.
He also offered these lesser
wives to visitors for the night
by way of hospitality,
but according to custom,
any children these visitors
produced were regarded as
Moshoeshoe's own children.
Again, in the West,
chastity, monogamy is valued,
who the father is.
In under-populated cultures,
in cultures that have responded
to under population it's the
children that are wanted,
and the mechanism of
biologically fathering a child
is much less important.
I experienced this myself quite
surprisingly.
I think I mentioned I had been
in Borneo living with some
headhunters for a while,
and I got along pretty well
with the young guys.
Sort of the guys stay together
and so after I was there a
little bit they offered me their
sisters and said,
'you shouldn't be sleeping
alone,' and for discretion,
I won't tell you what happened.
Even nowadays many African
scholars maintain that African
societies don't even really
distinguish between legitimate
and illegitimate births.
15% to 25% of women in various
west and east African countries,
including Kenya for instance,
report premarital births,
so they may or may not marry
the guy that's there before
marriage.
As all these estimates of
behavior that is now becoming
with the Christianization and
the Islamization becoming
somewhat questionable,
if the official statistics are
15% to 25% for sure it's a lot
larger than that.
Of course the husband again
isn't really wildly happy about
all this playing around and--but
what's most important to him is
his status.
Again, the biological parentage
of the child is less important.
He knows whatever child his
wife has will be officially his,
but he doesn't want to get to
be known as impotent.
His potency is what matters to
him.
As long as the woman--and this
happens a lot because very often
the man is quite significantly
older than the wife,
especially younger--as he gets
older and accumulates more
wives,
then younger wives,
and so his potency may really
be flagging quite a bit,
so it's a real concern.
As long as--if the wife--as
long as the wife is discreet and
doesn't make a public display
that this kid is really someone
else's then not a big problem.
The legal father accepts the
child;
the community accepts the child.
Anthropologists of course
thought this was very
interesting and they--
one wonderful--Susan Watkins
from The University of
Pennsylvania,
a sociologist,
works in Kenya in the Luo,
with the Luo on the west of
Kenya;
Luo people.
She got together a focus group
of women to discuss this issue.
It's a long thing,
I'll just tell you a little bit
from it,
and so Susan says,
"So sometimes women were
unfaithful,"
pretending a Western
perspective and the women said,
"Yes being unfaithful
started a long time ago,"
another woman:
"Long ago the older woman,
the elder women,
would tell us that the only
time you could sleep with
another man was if your husband
was not able to make you
pregnant,
but it's not that way
anymore."
The moderator again asks,
"Once you got the baby of
the other man,
was it for your husband or the
other man?"
Notice the for is taken for
granted that this is a gift,
and who did you make the gift
for, is it a gift for your
husband or a gift for the other
man.
The women are somewhat
incredulous, "Of course it
is for your husband.
The other man is just like a
bull;
doesn't your cow wander and
mate with another bull from the
next field?
When the cow gives birth,
is the calf yours or is the
calf the owner of the other
bull?
Of course it's yours."
All the women join in.
It's a wonderful kind of little
story.
In this the women are kind of
incredulous that Susan Watkins
herself does not have any cows.
They sort of presume that in
their answers that she does.
It's also pretty obvious how
sort of matter of fact the women
are about men's limited
biological role,
as one might say.
There's no romanticization of
the relationship,
none of the Western fetish
about biological paternity.
Not only is extra-marital
fertility not frowned on in the
same way that is,
at least officially here in the
West,
but premarital promiscuity is
reasonably acceptable.
Maybe not surprisingly,
you all know about truck
drivers going around spreading
AIDS from village to village,
guess who else spreads AIDS?
School teachers;
so a school teacher is someone
who has an education,
has been perhaps in the capital
or some big city,
has actually been to some sort
of secondary or college
education,
and has an income,
a white collar job,
a steady income from the
government--
teachers are in much demand.
This is a very high status
person and he's
assigned--finishes college,
he's assigned to some village
in the bush.
He's maybe the--the only--the
highest status person,
so what do the parents of all
the eligible daughters do?
They bring their daughter to
them and offer him,
'try out my daughter,' and
which sometimes they do and
sometimes they don't.
The statistics are now very
clear that these teachers have
picked up AIDS in the city and
they are one of the roots of
spreading AIDS in the villages.
Along with this loose attitude
toward paternity,
toward who is exactly the
father, the children then are
held a lot to a large degree in
common.
The idea of a nuclear family,
we have a mother and a father
of well defined pair,
their children no question
about who are their children,
an idea of a nuclear family is
not common there.
30% to 50%--when they survey,
30% to 50% of the children are
not living in the compound with
their biological mother or
father in either case.
Nuclear family is--very,
very simple things define a
nuclear family.
How frequently does he eat his
main meal--does a man eat his
main meal with his wife?
This gets studied.
How often he eats his main meal
with his children?
These are things that we take
just absolutely for granted.
How frequently does his wife go
with him when he visits friends?
with him when he visits
relatives?
How much of his free time does
he spend with his wife and
children?
The studies of this over the
years, there's a good study in
Kenya for instance,
and the answer to all these are
"rarely".
There's a very low degree of
nucleation of the families.
Again, this is changing and
families are becoming more and
more nucleated and one of the
things that's studied is the
percentage of people in
marriages that are considered
nuclear.
The last statistic that I saw
was 21%--only about one-fifth of
families were what we would call
nuclear families.
Just that idea of a tight-knit
family, exclusive in many ways,
is just not a common sort of
thing.
Another result of this attitude
is what we might call
quasi-prostitution.
In that traditional system the
father, the husband,
is not necessarily required to
provide economic support to the
children.
He is probably a rich man or
has some land,
he gives that to his wife,
if he has several wives he
divides it up among the wives.
They then grow the food on the
land;
they also have to do some work
on his land because men don't
want to work,
and so the wife has the
responsibility for the children.
She must get the money for
health, she must get the money
for education,
she does the farming on her
land.
This puts the women in
difficult strait and they're
always needing resources and if
another man can come in and
provide some resources for her
and her children,
well that's okay.
And so a fair amount of sex
involves, shall we say,
a gift from the person.
It's certainly not considered
prostitution in that culture but
we might use that word for it.
It's a very necessary part of
the whole system that resources
can come into the mother/child
family other than from the legal
husband who may or may not
provide very much.
Now all of the--the whole way
this society is set up favors
having a large number of
children in many different ways.
For instance,
consider land tenure.
The idea of private property
that one guy owns one plot of
land,
it's a new idea there and
traditionally the village or the
community held a bunch of
property.
They would defend this against
other villages,
so in a sense it was some
communities' property,
and there was constant raiding
and constant contestation,
but they would try to defend
their territory.
Within the territory the land
did not belong to any individual
and this was totally rational
because again very high death
rates,
hard to keep people alive,
so one family would die out,
have no descendants,
another family would have many
children.
So each generation the land
just gets redistributed;
more or less equal amounts of
land per child,
however many children that you
have, and again land is not
especially limiting.
The result is that if a male
wants to be powerful and have a
lot of land,
which means that if one part of
land goes fallow for some
reason,
he has other land,
so he wants to have a lot of
children.
They all are guaranteed land,
and the more children he has,
sons usually the case,
the more his financial
security,
his hunger security,
and his power goes up.
The society supports this by
giving land to whatever children
there are.
This is now breaking up because
it's becoming impossible,
and again, there are studies in
Kenya that in 1981 the average
land holding was 5.1 acres.
The agronomists say,
and the local people are aware
of this,
that about 4 acres of--with
their technology of farming at
that time,
about 4 acres of good land are
required,
and intense cultivation you
have to really work it,
were required to support a
family of the size of the
father's generation.
Even at that time the system
was to divide the land more or
less equally among the sons.
Well if you take 5.1 acres and
the average number of children
was four you get down to about
one acre,
which is way below the amount
of land that can support a
family.
A crisis has eventuated and a
variety of things happened that
when the economy is good in
Kenya,
which is occasionally,
there are jobs in the cities
and everyone hopes that one of
their sons,
at least one will go off to the
city and get a job and send back
remittances,
but a lot of the time the
economy is bad and the sons have
to stay on the land,
or migrate to the city without
a job and become this kind of
urban proletariat.
Under the influence of this
pressure the number of children
that of--
the average males wants has
gone down from five to about
three,
but still if you have two or
three acres and you divide it up
three ways it's an impossible
situation.
The sons cannot live on the
land that you have given.
So while everybody is
aware--there's no ignorance or
stupidity involved--
everybody is aware of the
situation,
the cultural prodding is so
strong,
the history is so strong that
the father's don't want to
reduce their desire for sons.
What has actually happened is
the number of sons desired has
shrunk but from 4.5 to three,
and currently,
if they divide up their land
each child gets a half an acre,
whereas four are necessary to
support the family.
In respect to the work on the
farm,
that the man will usually own
it, that varies in different
parts of Africa,
own it in some sense while he's
alive.
It goes back to the village on
his death.
In this slash and burn
agriculture that really
pre-modern people use,
the women do almost all the
work.
The only thing that the men do
is work that women are basically
physically incapable of doing,
which in this case if you're
living in the forest,
is clearing the land,
chopping down the trees,
hauling away the logs,
and this the men do.
It's heavy labor but it lasts
about two weeks out of the year
and the whole rest of the year
it's the women doing the work.
This--and men don't like--in
traditional these--
I mean traditional--every
period is traditional,
some period it is traditional,
but whatever period you're
talking about is traditional to
some later period so it's not a
great term.
Giving you a comparison in 1784
when the United States was being
settled,
there were 6,000 Iroquois
spread across New York state but
they were competing for land
with 240,000 New Yorkers of
European descent;
6,000 versus 240,000.
One tribe, the Oneida from
upstate--
and I was actually born up
there, had only 600 members to
the whole tribe,
but they inhabited 6,000,000
acres of land.
This is what's talked about by
population--low population
density, 600 people on 6,000,000
acres.
As in Africa,
the women did most of the
farming, they had a kind of
slash and burn agriculture also,
and the women did most of the
farming.
Well some of the colonists were
friendly to the Indians and
wanted to help the Indians so
they would suggest repeatedly
that why don't you take up
farming,
that with your hunter and
gatherer culture you're never
going to have enough people to
resist the Europeans.
If you want to resist the
Europeans and maintain some of
your land you have to increase
your population,
and the only way to do that is
you've got to go to agriculture.
The men refused to do that and
they--one quote one of the
Iroquois, "Farming is
women's work.
Man was not made to go to work
in the earth like a hedge hog,
but to go to war and
hunting."
Given that women are doing the
work in many cultures,
they are very valuable,
and so bride price comes from
this idea that--
in some sense you're buying a
woman and she is going to work
for you and there is a very
rough generalization that in
cultures where the women do the
work,
and the farming work
especially, the man--
the bride price will go from
the man to the woman's family.
In other places like India,
many places in India where the
women do not do the work but are
sequestered and kept at home
maybe covered up or something,
but only do internal household
work, then it reverses.
Then the man is taking care of
the woman and the woman's family
must pay the man or the man's
family, a dowry situation.
The issue of dowry and bride
price is extremely complicated
and cultures handle it very
differently, but that's sort of
the rough generalization.
Polygyny results from this;
since land is traditionally not
limiting but the number--you
need women to work the land.
Men of course want as many
wives as possible,
possibly also for sexual
reasons of course.
Again, comparing North Africa
with Sub-Saharan Africa,
in North Africa and the Middle
East about 1% to 7% of men are
polygamists.
It happens, it's condoned,
but it's kind of a rare thing
in the Mediterranean zone.
Even in the nineteenth century,
Mormons, again desert people in
the United States,
less than 10% of the men were
polygamists.
The maximum of course is 50%,
polygamy can never go beyond
50% of the men because if one
man have two wives,
then another man has no wives,
so 50% of the--
maximum 50%--if they're limited
to two wives and maximum 50% of
the men can be polygamists.
And if some are allowed more
than two wives,
or can manage to get more than
two wives, then that maximum
goes down.
In Sub-Saharan Africa,
and this is 1989 data,
in different places 12% to 38%
of the African men are in
polygamous marriages.
If they're limited to two and
50% is a max,
those places where polygamy is
38% of the men,
means that most of the women
are in polygamists
relationships.
Again, as we saw in New Guinea,
now a widow is very valuable,
again the women are doing the
work for you,
and so in Senegal,
for instance,
95% of the women who are
widowed remarry within five
years and 75% of these widows
are married polygamously to a
man that already has wives.
Compare that to an equally
poverty stricken culture like
Bangladesh this almost never
happens, that widows don't get
remarried in Bangladesh.
Polygamy, contrary to the way
we often perceive it as an abuse
of women,
it is not usually considered an
abuse there,
and women will often choose a
polygamous marriage over a
monogamous one.
Because what they want is a man
with resources,
and such a man will probably
already have some wives.
The other wives act as a safety
net and a support group,
so if the woman gets sick,
or her farming doesn't go well
that year,
or for whatever reason she can
have a group of other women who
will help her in a mutual kind
of aid society.
When a woman gets sick,
and again sickness in
pre-medical societies,
their sick a much greater
fraction of the time then we
are,
and it's a big part of their
lives and they have to prepare
for it.
They have children to take care
of and yet they're sick,
the other women can come in.
Also if they're circumcised and
not--in some of the severe ways
and not say enjoying sexuality;
the burden sometimes in many of
these cultures the idea of
female pleasure,
in some case it's known,
in some cases it's not known,
and it may be very painful if
she's had a circumcision
operation,
so the burden--so sexuality can
be considered a burden on the
women,
but if there's many wives that
burden is spread around.
In many ways polygamy is an
advantageous situation for a
woman to be in.
One anecdote here:
in Kenya a white French woman
anthropologist married an
illiterate Maasai warrior.
She said, and she wrote a
biography,
she said that despite their
cultural differences she and her
Maasai husband,
as well as his other wives,
got along famously.
She wrote this memoir and it
was originally entitled,
The Six Wives of My
Husband.
In a later edition it was
amended to The Nine Wives of
My Husband.
In between he took three more
wives.
I think you get the idea of
what goes on in a society where
land is not limiting,
people are limiting.
Now to contrast this whole
system to that--in the temperate
zones;
agriculture is much more
productive in the temperate
zones.
The key switch is where a
single man can,
by his agricultural efforts,
or a woman depending,
can produce more food then he
and his--
whatever his family unit is,
can consume so that there's an
agricultural surplus.
In hunter/gatherer societies
there's basically no surplus and
a lot of the early traditional
African societies,
there's basically no surplus.
With this surplus,
of course, they have more
children, the children are kept
alive;
there's enough food for the
children, and the population
starts growing,
and eventually you fill up the
land.
In this Lesotho story that
I'm--this history-- there's
several books on the history,
the Bantu people,
who again, I mentioned this,
started in West Africa,
move east to just under the
Sahel and then come down the
east coast of Africa,
and at the period in the 1700s
they're sort of moving into
southern Africa where conditions
are pretty decent.
Who's there? The Bushmen.
And they are kind of pushing
the Bushmen out of this part of
Africa in the 1700s.
The land is,
as they see it,
is open because the Bushmen are
very,
very sparse,
they're not a threat of any
sort and mostly the Bantus seem
to take the Bushmen's wives.
They don't seem to bother to
kill the Bushmen,
just take their wives.
Later on, by the 1800s,
the land starts to get filled
up and then not only do the
Basotho of Lesotho,
the people call themselves
Basotho,
start having conflicts among
themselves but the neighboring
groups,
another Bantu group the Zulu--a
big group generally called Zulu
start getting politic--
they start getting politically
organized,
they try to get land and you
have tremendous wars in Zululand
which also slops over into the
Basutoland and tremendous
destruction,
tremendous dislocation.
Again, eventually the land
fills up when you have the kind
of decent agriculture that you
have--
you can have in the Lesotho,
which was again temperate zone
and that south enough in Africa
to be below the desert zone.
The land fills up and all kinds
of things change.
People come into conflict,
and because individuals can
produce more children than are
needed to work the land,
each individual can produce
more food than is required,
the excess children must go off
and become basically landless
peasants looking for scarce work
or go into some villages,
which eventually become cities,
and become landless laborers,
and the urban poor.
Meanwhile, since there is this
excess,
now it becomes worthwhile for
some people to get control of
others,
because that surplus,
in a situation where each man
just produces enough for himself
and his wife and children,
if it's the man doing the work,
then there's no sense capturing
him and enslaving him
politically--
controlling him politically
because he doesn't have any
surplus to give you,
for you to take.
Once agriculture is productive
enough so that he has surplus
then he has something worth
taking and you start getting the
chief--
the chief's want to become
kings and they want to take over
your land,
and they want to control you,
and they want to get your
surplus.
Actually civilization starts
that way because with the
surplus they buy luxury
ornaments,
and they have craftsmen,
and they have trade,
and they have scholars,
and they have priests and all
this kind of stuff because not
every man is needed to farm the
land.
You both have,
as a result of an increasing
population density,
the rise of civilization and
the rise of a lot of the horrors
of civilization in these massive
wars and massive poverty.
This understanding of the
dangers of overpopulation have
been perceived for a long time,
surprisingly early in history,
when local regions got filled,
but even surrounding them there
could be lots of empty space.
Here's a Greek epic from around
700 B.C.
"There was a time when the
countless tribes of man
oppressed the surface of the
earth,
of the deep bosomed
earth," deep bosom meaning
deep soil,
deep soil earth,
"and Zeus saw it and he
had pity on the earth,
and in his wise heart resolved
to relieve the all-nurturing
earth of men by causing the
great struggle of the Trojan
War,
that the load of death might
empty the world."
Again, this is his explanation
for the--
whoever wrote this
epic--explanation for the Trojan
War,
that it was a Malthusian thing,
that the earth got too crowded,
people couldn't support
themselves anymore and they had
to be cleaned off.
About 900 years later,
Tertullian, a Roman theologian
echoes this;
200 A.D.
"The earth is currently
more cultivated and developed
than at early times.
Now all places are accessible,
all are full of activity;
everywhere there is a dwelling,
everywhere a multitude,
everywhere a government,
everywhere there is life.
We are burdensome to the world.
The resources are scarcely
adequate to us,
and complaints are everywhere
while already nature does not
sustain us."
Tertullian continues,
"Truly pestilence and
hunger,
and war, and flood must be
considered as a remedy for
nations like a pruning back of
the human race becoming
excessive in numbers."
That's quite lovely.
Of course the Europeans are not
the only ones to worry about
population.
In China, in 500 B.C.,
Han Fei Tzu complained,
"People at present think
that five sons are not too many,
and each son has five sons
also, and before the death of
the grandfather there are
already 25 descendants."
The women aren't counted.
"Therefore,
people are more and wealth is
less.
They work hard and receive
little."
This growing population density
is well understood to be causing
problems.
One of the problems that
happens at population density is
that communicable
diseases--there's many,
many problems.
As the population gets denser,
the wars become larger,
maybe not as a percentage of
the population but you have
these enormous wars with
enormous numbers of deaths.
Another thing is disease starts
spreading, communicable disease
because the population is dense
enough that the disease does not
die out.
Again, this is local even
though at the time of the
Peloponnesian War in Greece,
about 420 B.C.,
it was written about in 420,
a lot of that world was not
crowded,
but Athens--the Athens area was
indeed crowded,
and Athens itself was crowded,
and during the war they had a--
everybody had to get into the
city and the city was blockaded
and the population density in
the city was large enough that a
plague,
some sort of plague,
we don't know what the disease
was, broke out.
This is Thucydides describing
this, "Words indeed fail
when one tries to give a general
picture of this disease."
He's writing The
Peloponnesian War as--how
many of you read The
Peloponnesian War or some
pieces of it?
A few;
it's very interesting.
"Words indeed fail when
one tries to give a general
picture of this disease,
and as for the sufferings of
individuals,
they seemed almost beyond the
capacity of human nature to
endure.
People were dying like sheep,
they died like flies,
the bodies of the dying were
heaped one on top of the other,
and half dead creatures could
be seen staggering about in the
streets,
or flocking around the
fountains in the desire for
water.
The temples in which they took
up their quarters were full of
the dead bodies of people who
had died inside them."
He goes on to describe the
result of this plague which is
the people going through
emotional despair,
civil society just collapses,
and all kinds of lawlessness
breaks out.
In later Europe,
Europe underwent huge
vicissitudes of population.
In the classic ages,
up through Rome,
through the whole Roman Empire,
the population of the
Mediterranean world was clearly
increasing;
whatever data we have always
points to that.
Then starting with the Dark
Ages, maybe as early as 300 or
400,
Europe gets invaded by all
kinds of "barbarian
hordes,"
as they are perceived by the
Romans.
First, it's the Germanic
tribes, then it's the Huns,
then it's the Saracens,
then it's the Vikings.
By the year 1000,
European population is
extremely cut down;
European civilization is cut
down, and we don't really have
good ideas of why all these
invasions stopped.
One history that I particularly
like says the reason they
stopped, there was nothing left
worth taking in Europe.
About 1000 the invasions
stopped and then civilization
started recovering,
and it only took about 200
years for Europe to basically
repopulate itself.
When you have land,
when you have space,
people then have a lot of
children, and keep them alive.
In these good years,
it was good climate at that
time also,
life expectancies in the 1200s
were between 35 and 40 years
old,
which is very good for this
very early era.
Then around 1250 the population
stopped increasing,
and for another 100 years or
so, it was more or less level.
When you find a level
population that means there's
something limiting,
some block, and they can't grow
beyond this block.
Historians attribute it to the
whole sort of a state of culture
there, so the land was not owned
by peasants.
So the peasants--if you your
own land you'll have a lot of
interest in farming it maximally
and improving it,
and doing stuff and when
someone else owns the land,
you don't have much interest in
that and the worse the
conditions you're under,
the less interest you have in
improving the land for the
landowner because he's going to
take as much as he can away from
you and leave you just the bare
amount that you can live on.
At this time the Catholic
Church was by far the biggest
landowner in Europe,
and they owned 30% to 50% of
all the productive lands in
Europe.
The peasants on the land were
serfs and lived in this extreme
poverty, and they were not
allowed to leave the estate;
they were stuck to living in
that kind of condition.
The ones that--well the church
itself got very rich.
This is a period of the
tremendous dominance of the
church.
The income from church lands,
going to church nobility and to
Rome,
was ten times larger and all
the church lands--
you had all the crown lands of
the crowns in Europe.
The church got ten times as
much income from their lands as
did the so-called civil
authorities.
The civil authorities
controlled what was left of the
land,
the kings and so forth,
and it turns out that the serfs
on the civil land had somewhat
better conditions,
somewhat more rights than on
church lands.
On church lands they were
really the lowest of the low,
but on civil lands they had
somewhat better situations,
but they were still deep in
poverty.
Because of this serfs just
continued,
they were totally uneducated
and totally illiterate,
and so they continued to farm
the small plots just as they had
done for centuries,
and so the productivity of the
land did not increase and the
population could not increase.
Europe was full so there was no
place that a serf could just get
away and start his own farm with
someone else because that land
was owned already by someone
else.
In the cities which were
beginning a little bit,
the Guilds were trying to keep
members away,
they were closed,
they only took children of the
members of the Guild,
there was no way for someone to
rise up and become a craftsman.
Historians describe this in
about 1300 as a Malthusian
situation that it's--
we'll talk more about Malthus
later,
but a demographic and economic
situation where you just can't
support more people.
The productivity of your system
is just not enough to provide
for any more population then you
have and that if population
rises something is going to
come--
happen to knock it down again.
The thing that happened in
Europe in this era is the
plague.
The plague first hit Europe in
Sicily in 1347,
the previous time it had been
there was six to seven centuries
ago,
in what's called the Justinian
Pandemic,
near the end of the Roman
Empire.
The plague spread throughout
Europe killing millions and
millions of people.
There was wave after wave of
this and there was a wave in
1347, as I said,
the biggest and initial wave.
Then again in 1360,1371,
1381,1388, 1398,
and every few years the plague
would come through again and
kill lots of people.
Numbers are hard to come by,
most estimates say that about
1/3 of Europe was killed by the
plague.
Numbers can range from 1/6 of
Europe to 1/2 of Europe,
but massive,
massive death and brought
Europe back down to below what
you might call its carrying
capacity with the then current
technology.
Plague--they don't know why the
plague came into Europe at
exactly this time,
and it may have been a random
event but the--
one of the more reasonable
ideas is that plague kills,
and plague is endemic in Asia,
but it has to get from Asia to
Europe,
and if someone were traveling
from Asia to Europe they would
be dead--
before this period--they would
be dead long ago from the
plague.
But in the early Middle Ages,
travel--
shipping and all kinds of
travel were getting better and
faster,
and so one of the things the
plague may have been able to get
to Europe because a ship leaving
the Black Sea is where they
caught it from,
could get to Sicily before
everyone who had the plague--
everybody on the ship was dead.
That's one hypothesis.
It took from this nice high
level in 1250 and so forth,
stagnant period,
and then it was knocked down.
It took hundreds of years,
minimum 200 years before the
population of Europe recovered
to its 1300--
1340 levels--and some
historians think it didn't
really recover until about 1715,
so 400 years or something to
recover from this.
The plague continued for
hundreds of years and more than
300 years after the plague
started, it killed more than
70,000 people in London alone;
one city.
This is Daniel Defoe,
The Journal of the Plague
Year;
some of you have probably read
that, really horrible,
so that's 1664 and 1665,
more than 300 years after the
plague starts.
One of the reasons it's
persisted is they--
the people had absolutely no
idea what was causing the
plague,
absolutely no idea what to do
to protect yourself from the
plague,
no real idea of contagion or
contamination and there was no
science whatsoever.
This was before the
enlightenment,
before rational attitudes
towards all these things.
What would someone believe back
then not having any sort of real
understanding of the whole
disease process and infection
process?
Pretty obvious,
it's God's punishment.
Humans are sinful,
we all know that and so God is
punishing you.
Well what do you do if you've
been a bad boy?
You have to get punished.
Penitence.
And people would whip
themselves, they're called the
flagellants and--have any of you
seen The Seventh Seal?
Ingmar Bergen;
this is a great movie,
it starts--it's set at this
time in Europe and the opening
scene is sort of a bleak,
barren European landscape with
a long line of Pilgrims going
through each one with a whip,
beating the guy bloody,
the guy in front of him.
This is atoning for their sins
and this was a way that they
intended to try to stay alive.
What was the actual result of
this?
They're weakening themselves,
they're cutting holes in their
skin which is a barrier to
penetration--flea bites;
flea bites carry plagues--so
these were sick,
desperate people and they were
going from town to town.
They would pick up plague in
one town,
carry it to the next,
so the very mechanisms by which
they were trying to keep the
plague away was exactly one of
the major mechanisms of the
spread of the plague.
You read the history at the
time, there are all kinds of
crazy--what we consider crazy
things that they tried.
So syphilis was introduced to
Europe at about that time from
the new world,
so we're talking 150 years
later, and while it was a new
thing on the horizon and a
number of doctors somehow got
the idea that syphilis would
protect you against the plague.
One of the standard cures was
to get infected with syphilis as
a form of protection from the
plague.
As far as we can tell,
this was a remedy taken up only
by rich people;
whether it's true or not I
don't know.
The plague, being a very major
demographic event,
knocking the population of
Europe way down,
was one of the seminal
landmarks in European
civilization and marked a
complete change in how European
civilization developed.
I described medieval Europe as
having this sort of Malthusian
kind of land lock,
that things were unchanging and
couldn't change because no one
was allowed to do change,
and then all of a sudden you
get the Black Death,
and then immediately after the
Black Death you get the
renaissance.
What happens is a lot of
fluidity,
people can leave the church
estates,
can leave their lords' estates,
there's plenty of empty land,
they go out there,
they can farm themselves,
the Guilds don't have members,
they can join Guilds,
they can do technology,
they can move around,
all kinds of things turn up.
The first and most virulent
wave of the plague lasted from
1340s to 1400,
and the next generation was the
core of the renaissance.
So 1420, Brunelleschi designs
the Great Dome over the
cathedral in Florence,
Ghiberti is creating the Great
Bronze Doors for the Door of
Florence's Baptistery,
and Donatello makes the first
David.
I don't know if you ever--you
know Michelangelo's David,
but Donatello made a very
delicate one before him which is
sort of very different but
equally beautiful.
Da Vinci, Michelangelo all
worked in the 1400s,
Machiavelli,
the Medicis,
all of this century and at the
end of the century,
1492, Columbus discovers
America.
You have--you go from this
extremely tight,
locked in medieval thing
lasting hundreds of years where
basically almost everybody is
miserable unless you were a lord
or a bishop and then boom you
reduce the population pressure
and the world explodes in
creativity.
Now that's--not everybody had
to agree that that was the
seminal event that caused the
renaissance in some--
nothing is that simple,
but it clearly was one of the
major things that one has to
consider in describing why did
the Renaissance happen.
There were of course
antecedents to the renaissance
before that,
and as I've said,
European civilizations started
recovering in the year 1000 well
before the plague.
There's a simplistic
explanation but certainly an
important part of what was going
on.
Now we're almost out of time,
but even after the renaissance,
and continuing up into
surprisingly modern times,
people still lived very badly.
Better than before but still
badly,
so from the time of the Black
Death until the industrial
revolution started making things
better,
we're talking something like
1350 to maybe 1850,
we can push that back to 1800
if you want.
We have about 500 years,
again, where the population
pressure is not great,
civilization is improving--is
making great advances in terms
of art,
or culture, exploration of the
world,
but the common man doesn't
really see much improvement in
the situation at all.
The population is still
overwhelmingly made up of
peasants,
just living on the edge of
existence,
and this is a description,
a typical house in Europe in
the late Middle Ages is made of
wood or various scraps of
vegetable material,
mixed with mud or clay.
The roof is of straw or reeds,
the floor is of dirt,
and there's a pit in the middle
for fire.
If it is winter the family
huddles cold together around the
fire in semi-darkness,
with the animals nearby for
warmth;
one of the reasons for living
with the animals is for the
warmth that the animals produce.
They don't understand
ventilation and in ventilation
you bring in cold air,
you heat it,
and you let it go out so they
don't want the cold air coming
in so they close themselves up,
but they need a fire to keep
from freezing,
so the room is filled with
smoke with maybe a small hole
for the smoke to go out,
so they're not breathing fresh
air.
This is a description of the
late Middle Ages,
300 years later there's little
progress.
One of the great French
historians, George Huppert has
studied a village in France in
the 1600s, and there's a village
about 500 to 700 people.
"One-third of the babies
died in their first year,
another third died before
adulthood,
thus only one-third survived to
reach their reproductive
ages."
Remember I showed you that
graph from Roman times,
same story, 1500 years and
basically no progress.
"The little children who
managed to survive were good
looking but,
if they reached the age of 10
or 12,
they had already assumed the
generally unpleasant appearance
of adults.
The people tended to be
stunted, bent over,
and of a yellowish complexion.
They did not look healthy.
Their bellies were
distended,"
lack of protein,
"They moved slowly,
they had poor teeth,
their growth was retarded."
He has village records from
this era,
"Of the 350 births only
145 would reach adulthood and
marry in turn,
but of the 75 female survivors
marriage was almost
universal,"
again if a woman managed to
survive she was going to be
married and start childbearing.
Since they were unhealthy,
they didn't have good
nutrition,
the girls did not reach menses
until about the age of 18,
and finally they started
menstruating and became fertile,
and so they married late about
age 23,
they just weren't healthy
enough to engage in a marriage
before then.
Childbearing was almost
universal--marriage and
childbearing was almost
universal and we'll see this
again in China,
but maternal death severely cut
short the period of
childbearing.
Having a child itself was
extremely dangerous and of the
third--
of the one-third that reached
marriageable age,
most couples had only one or
two children before either the
husband or the wife died.
So again the limitation on the
number of children is poor
nutrition,
late maturity,
leading to late marriage,
and then early death and they
have only one or two children.
The end result of his
statistics isthat,
by the time 100 female children
of the preceding generation had
died or finished their
reproductive years,
they had produced only 70
daughters.
The population was not
replacing itself.
This is one of those situations
where, if no one comes in from
the outside, that village is
going to go extinct.
There were other places with
apparently somewhat better
agriculture that did produce a
surplus of children and they
wandered around looking for some
home and the village made up
this deficit by marrying excess
people.
Maybe the daughter
of--daughters of transient
artisans or laborers,
and again, as we saw in the
under populated areas of New
Guinea,
when a man died leaving a wife,
no time was wasted.
The widows and widowers
remarried right away.
If--since land was so scarce
that a lot of the marriages,
and another reason for the late
marriage, was they had to wait
until the father died.
That was important for working
the land that there was so much
that could support so many
people,
and you had so much labor that
was required to work that land,
the father died,
that's one--they die fairly
young,
when they're still being able
to work,
so that labor is gone,
you have to take in a wife to
replace the labor of the dead
father,
then the children come on and
the generation keeps repeating.
This situation in France was
characteristic of France for 400
years, and during that time the
population just hovered around
20 million.
It came out of the Black Death
and it rose to 20 million and
then they were not able to get
over that for the ballpark of
400 years.
In--I think--I'll just tell you
that the population started to
recover then late in this
period,
and by 1560 it had really
returned to the 20 million
before the Black Death;
this is France,
but then religious fervor
starts up.
In the wars of the sixteenth
and seventeenth century and you
know --
the wars between the Catholics
and the Protestants in Europe,
and previously,
the Christians had religious
wars always against Islam.
They were--that was the main
enemy,
the Turks were very strong and
much more advanced then the
Europeans and they were
battering at the doors of
Europe.
They surrounded Vienna,
and so all of the military
activity was of religious origin
was against the Turks.
That threat receded and now you
have the reformation and now you
have two--
both Christian religious groups
in Europe and they start going
after each other.
About a quarter to half of the
German speaking people of
Central Europe were killed in
this period, it was really most
severe in Europe.
In France it was sort of
stamped out that early on in
this period Protestants were
doing very well in France.
They had a large fraction of
the population.
Have you heard of St.
Bartholomew's Day?
On that day the--it also had to
do with the royal succession--
the Catholic forces got
together and just slaughtered
all the Protestants they could
find and that sort of stopped
the reformation in France.
Europe again went through then
130 years of this
Catholic/Protestant bloodletting
before they finally realized
that this was not a wise thing
to do.
We'll continue with what
happens to European civilization
after these slaughters--the
religious slaughter dies down.
See you on Tuesday.